the arts district in downtown las vegas
is filled with even more food and music
this weekend the fourth annual black las
vegas food festival is bringing a lot of
fun to the area victoria saha is live
tonight with this great assignment she
gives us a look at what what you can
find there hey victoria
hey sasha so many vendors are out here i
know you can hear the music we're
grooving to it but i wish you were here
to smell the delicious food that all
these vendors are whipping up for us
tonight there's so many vendors here
like i said but they say that it's so
important to come together and support
each other
music food clothing and so much more the
black food festival has brought in
dozens of different vendors from all
over the country to allow the las vegas
community to get a glimpse of the unique
things the black culture has to offer
the owner of gourmet soul says feeding
people is his passion like many of the
vendors he doesn't have a brick and
mortar store which is why a festival
like this that allowed for vendors to
take part with a reasonable fee means so
much for his business as an event
it was a beautiful thing fellowshipping
you know i mean everybody coming
together as one other different
businesses
you can't beat it right downtown las
vegas i mean right here you know casino
center i mean you can't beat it other
people attending say it's great to see
not just a black community take part but
other cultures as well
now if you missed out on today you can
come back tomorrow that tomorrow is the
last day for the event i'm going to go
ahead and finish eating reporting from
the arts district victoria live local
now